hey everyone so I'm checking out
Logitech G 924 suite at they design for
Xbox one it also works on PC there's a
few games that working with right now I
think project cars is one game Forza
Motorsport 6 which is the game I'm gonna
be trying out with this now is also
compatible and this thing is kind of
amazing
now the gear shift is sold separately
for $60 so that doesn't come with the
wheel but the wheel and the pedals go
for $400
but this is some high quality stuff I
mean we're talking about a leather
wrapped steering wheel this gives you
force feedback at vibrates it auto turns
to get you straightened out on the road
it is fully featured it's got stainless
steel features the pedals it's got a gas
brake and a clutch everything is
adjustable if you had we don't obviously
have a gaming chair here but if you had
a gaming chair you could actually mount
this and the pedals into the frame of
the chair so I'm gonna start this race I
have not been playing this game for a
while so you're probably gonna laugh a
little bit at my skills or lack thereof
but let's start while I'm using this for
the first time in four to six I'm
noticing the wheel is super sensitive
like the amount of resistance on this
wheel as you can see is crazy it feels
like the car is really struggling to
turn and the wheel is letting me know
just how tight these terms can be as I
skid off the road and into the grass but
that's fine so the wheel will
automatically adjust itself to twelve
o'clock
aside from my apparently awful racecar
driving skills this thing feels awesome
this product along with its $400 price
tag
probably best suited for somebody who is
a hardcore racecar driving simulator
game man I'm really frustrated with the
controls on the maybe it's I'm just not
I'm not good at this but it seems like
I'm doing it okay oh and I just got left
I really do think this is a high-quality
product from Logitech I'm just not very
good at it but if you love racing and
racing is your passion you're gonna love
it it's a lot of money though so just
keep that in mind and it only really
works with a couple games what it works
for PC as well so there you have it
you